Kyla's gary is there a way to drive
traffic to a website when posting
content directly to Facebook Kyle yes as
you can tell that Facebook post on my
fanpage drove a crapload of traffic to
my medium article which is content
Facebook you know I answered this
question because I wanted to show you
raw details because I think raw details
is even a deeper version of this show
and I continue to try to go deep within
myself to really drive you value
especially because this is only a 50
episode experiment just kidding uh and
so the answer is absolutely Facebook is
actually probably one of the biggest
drivers of content awareness outside of
itself to other destinations in the
world right now so the question is how
do you do it organically how do you do
it in a paid targeted wait what I just
showed you was organic I have a pretty
big foundation of 150,000 fans on that
page but there's people that I've seen
posted content that have 800 fans and
the enough people shared it and enough
people you know liked it and enough
people commented it and shared it not
only within Facebook but outside of it
that it created fire Facebook is is
content awareness infrastructure in a
2015 world so not only is there a way I
think it's one of these singular best
ways and so I would highly recommend
making an investment in facebook
fanpages recognizing the you know
distribution opportunities that it
creates for content you're putting
outside of its network oh crap wait
subscribe I need subscriptions because I
can't push this many right hooks in
social so subscribe